Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute gibt's eine Schritt-für-Schritt-Anleitung für den perfekten türkischen Reis.
Und es gibt immer die eine Variante vom türkischen Reis,
das ist die, die wir nicht so mögen,
das ist dieses klebrige, dieser weiße Reis.
(H: Ich mag das überhauuupt nicht!)
Das mögen wir jetzt nicht so.
Es gibt aber auch noch die andere Variante, das ist wirklich dieser traditionelle Reis,
wo dann auch noch die Nudeln mit reinkommen, was dann wirklich mit Langkornreis gemacht wird
und total fein ist und wo wirklich jedes Reiskorn zu sehen ist.
Also einfach nur locker und leicht.
(H: Das ist dieses şeri..?)
Şehriye heißt das bei uns.
(H: Bei uns shariya, okay.)
Genau, und dafür haben wir jetzt auch wirklich nur 5 Zutaten, die fünfte ist auch nur optional.
Also, ich hab hier Basmati Langkornreis, dann hab ich hier diese speziellen Nudeln,
das sind die şehriye Nudeln.
Natürlich Salz, etwas Sonnenblumenöl und die Zutat ist optional:
das ist ganz normale Butter.
Und was wir dann natürlich auch noch benötigen ist kochendes Wasser.
Und hier ist auch immer ganz wichtig: ihr habt gerade gesehen ich habe
1 Glas voller Reis, deshalb nehme ich 1 ½ Gläser voller Wasser.
Das ist immer ganz wichtig weil viele nehmen bei bestimmten Reissorten dann
1 Glas Reis und 2 Gläser Wasser.
Bei dem Langkornreis, den ich immer für den türkischen Reis verwende, immer nur 1 ½ Gläser Wasser
damit's eben nicht zu matschig wird.
So, der allererste Schritt - und das ist auch einer der wichtigsten -
ist dass wir den Reis einmal auswaschen. Da nehmt ihr einfach lauwarmes oder kaltes Wasser.
Und dann seht ihr schon, dass der Reis Stärke enthält.
Und die Stärke bewirkt einfach, dass es dann wenn ihr es nicht rauswascht,
total pampig und matschig wird und das wollen wir ja nicht.
Das heißt haltet mal euer Glas unten drunter und ihr seht: das Wasser ist trüb.
Und wenn ihr das dann lang genug auswascht, also so ungefähr 3-4min,
dann ist das Wasser, das unten rauskommt, komplett klar und die ganze Stärke ist raus.
Und wenn das erledigt ist, können wir rüber an den Herd und mit dem Topf einmal anfangen.
Im Topf wird jetzt zuallererst Öl erhitzt, da könnt ihr auch ruhig z.B. Stufe 6 von 9 nehmen.
Und da gebt ihr die Nudeln rein und die werden dann schön braun angebraten.
So, jetzt sind die Nudeln hellbraun, das hat jetzt ungefähr 1 ½ - 2min gedauert.
An der Stelle einmal den gewaschenen Reis dazugeben und für ca ½min mitbraten.
Sobald ihr den Reis dazugebt - ganz wichtig - geht mit der Stufe gerne runter
auf 3 oder schon auf 2 damit das eben nicht aufm Boden anpappt
und ihr müsst es auch ständig umrühren, das ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Und der Reis, der entwickelt auch Röstaromen, also ihr riecht dann so einen nussigen Geruch,
also ihr merkt das richtig. Und an der Stelle das gekochte Wasser dazugeben,
wie gesagt die 1 ½ Gläser jetzt in meinem Fall.
Und dann kommt auch schon das Salz dazu.
Und der Reis wird gegart, ganz ganz wichtig: den Deckel einmal schließen.
Und dann dauert das so ungefähr 18-20min, ich nehme immer Stufe 2 von 9.
Et voilà, der Reis ist fertig!
Und man sieht jetzt schon, dass der total fein ist weil die Reisspitzen so nach oben gucken.
Und deswegen habe ich auch am Anfang gesagt, dass die Zutat Butter optional ist.
Für mich ist er so schon perfekt und er schmeckt auch sehr, sehr gut.
Aber wenn ihr das so ein bisschen buttriger möchtet - ihr wisst ja Butter ist Geschmacksträger -
dann tut da gerne noch ein bisschen Butter rein nachdem das Ganze fertig gegart ist.
Ich nehm mir dafür jetzt ganz einfach immer teelöffelweise ein bisschen Butter
und nehmt dann um das Ganze aufzulockern einfach zwei Gabeln.
(H: Boah, die sind richtig körnig Kiki!)
Ja, das ist der perfekte türkische Reis! Der ist einfach nur perfekt!
So ihr Lieben, ich lass euch jetzt den Reis selber nachkochen zuhause, ich entlasse euch also!
Viel Freude beim Nachmachen, schaut hier unten in die Videobeschreibung
wenn ihr die ganz genauen Mengenangaben sehen möchtet.
Und dann könnt ihr mir auch gerne in die Kommentare schreiben, welches Basic Rezept ihr als nächstes sehen möchtet.
Unsere Idee war ja der arabische Reis, dass ich euch den gerne mal zeige
nach der Art meiner Schwiegermama, das ist nämlich auch echt lecker!
Ich weiß gar nicht, welchen ich besser finde.
(H: Natürlich der arabische Reis!)
Ich weiß nicht, ich find beide mega gut!
(H: Sag nichts falsches!)
Okay ich sag jetzt nichts falsches!
Und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachkochen,
hinterlasst dem Video gerne ein Däumchen nach oben wenn euch das Rezept gefällt.
Und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Video hier auf meinem Kanal.
Ciao ciao!